ينضم الينا من دبي الزميل ليث مازاري
مراسل صباح العربيه ليت يسعد صباحك المطعم
الايطالي تصدر قائمه تيست اطلس ماذا تقول
عنه اين انت موجود تحديدا مغشش الناس
يعني انا صباح الخير لكم
بالايطالي انا برفقه الشيف ايلاريا
الايطاليه للحديث عن المطبخ الايطالي الذي
يقدم الذ الوجبات طبعا برايك كثيرين والذي
يتصدر قائما افضل المطابخ لعام 2022 احنا
بشيك نونه همم
قالها اول سؤال يا سهام ونادين ليش المطبخ
الايطالي ب- معظم بلدان العالم هو نمبر
وان واي ده ايطاليان كيتشن اوركويزين از
نمبر وان انوس اوف ذا كاونترز
[ضحك]
المطبخ الايطالي
معنى ههه موزاريلا تعزجه من ايطاليا مع
التومات الطماطم الجاي برضو من ايطاليا
هذا الحلو بالموضوع عشان هيك المطبخ
الايطاليلا ايه ممكن كمان هيك تذكرنا
وتحكي للمشاهدين مثلا شو الاخبار والابرز
خمسه اطباق بالنسبه لايطاليا المشهورين
حول العالم
اكيد البيتزا الايطاليه
والموتزاريلا على فكره
شو هالريح يا جماعه
ههه وفي عندهم طبعا الحلويات الايطاليه
مشهوره كثير ومش بس هيك انا عجبني انا
بتعرفه لفات العالم اللي عجبني بكل بلد
زرته تكون الايد هويه الاطباق مهمه ما
بنسى اطباق
روبابيتنام الفراش دائما بحضروها من خضار
من الاسماك هذا برده له اثر بانه يخلي
هويه الطبق
استنى انه تخلص حكي
مش مشكله ابدا
الاطباق الحلو فيها انه بتكون بكل بلد
الهاويها ايش صار هلا هل تعلمون يا سهام
ونادين انه ثاني طبق بفرنسا شو تحذروا غير
انه همم الفرنسيه ثاني طبق الكباب الذي
يؤكل في فرنسا ليه لانه تعودوا عليه اجى
من ثقافه ثانيه جاء من والله العظيم جاء
من فيوجن اجا من بلاد خلطه المكونات وصار
هذا الطبق نمبر توبي فرنسا يعني انا برده
في شغله مع احترامنا لاصدقائنا اللبنانيه
المطاعم اللبنانيه اخذت صيد في فرنسا
اجوا من سوريا
صار برده يحط الكوزينه لانه الاوروبي تعود
انه كوزين لبنيز او المطبخ اللبناني فصار
انه قصيت للمطبخ اللبناني بغض النظر اذا
كان الشف هو سوري او من منطقه اخرى من
الوطن العربي او من المتوسط منطقه حوض
المتوسط وكذلك شفنا هالشيء بالياباني كثير
في مطاعم يابانيه انا شفتها بالعالم ما
بيقولوا ياباني بس لانه
المطبخ الياباني صاروا يقصدوا هذه المطاعم
الاساس انه هو مطعم ياباني
هل من خلال سفره وترحالك في معظم بلاد هذا
العالم لاحظت انه مطبخ العربي في انه همم
هويه عالميه الناس بتعرفه
نعم مش بس العربي اذكر تماما اطيب مطعم
افغاني اكل افغاني كان في بوستون في
مستشفى في امريكا فيعني صار انه المطابخ
لا لها علاقه بس انه الواحد الشخص من هديك
البلد صاروا يتقنه انا بذكر تماما بدنيا
غيتس وحده بتعمل كسكس الكسكس المغربي كانت
صينيه الشاف فهلا صاروا الشف مثل ما صغر
العالم لصغر المطبخ صار انه كلهم يتعلموا
من بعض ويقدمه اطباق مختلفه من من ثقافات
مختلفه في نفس المطبخ يعني هي موجوده في
مطعم ايطالي اكيد
في دبي ولكن هي ممكن تكون بتعمل اطباقلها
كويسين ار يو ار يو
يوتيوب
في الاكل الايطالي قالت كمان انا بطبخ اكل
اسباني فهذا نحكي عنه على كل حال بدي
اترككم لانه حان وقت الافطار الغداء مع
الشيف
والبيتزا جاهزه سعيده الف
صحه
شكرا لك يا ليث مزاري